hey guys how's it going so a bunch of
you guys were tweeting me for some
updates on some iPhone 7 news there
really hasn't been that much news but
this schematic was recently released in
I believe was in sort of Assam magazine
and it definitely would confirm there is
not going to be a headphone jack in the
iPhone 7 so that's kind of the biggest
sort of piece of the puzzle that will
confirm to us that no add headphone jack
that we also love and adore will no
longer be in the iPhone 7 so the problem
with this is I think that would lead
most people to think that the iPhone 7
will be thinner than the iPhone 6s or
the iPhone 6 but that's not really the
case most of the people are saying is
they think it's going to be almost
identical to the success but the antenna
band lines will be removed so really
it's not going to be thinner it's going
to be almost I dare to say identical to
the six other than a few very small
changes where you can see here on the
schematic the bottom part there is no
headphone jack which has been removed
from I guess if you're looking at the
phone from the left side so it does kind
of look like it's lighting port but
could also be USB see and I think at one
time it was rumored that there was going
to be a dual speakers so on both sides
which removing the headphone jack would
give enough room for that but here it
looks like that's definitely not going
to be the case it looks like the side
buttons will still be the same and the
screen everything looks almost identical
to the previous version so it's great
about this article is this guy also
shows us some possibilities of what it's
like in a dual camera so I think it's
pretty much been confirmed at this point
that you have the iPhone 7 or the iphone
7 pro if they do happen to release it so
as you can see so as you can see here
this will be aware of the dual camera
this will be where the dual cameras will
be on the iPhone 7 or the iphone 7 pro
because they could potentially go the
route I was reading I think somewhere
else
Apple said to release for new phones in
2016 so what that means is they're going
to be releasing the se which was already
out but they could potentially be
releasing a smaller version of the
iPhone
which would be the iPhone 7 and then
never the iPhone 7 plus and then the
iphone 7 pro which would lead us to four
phones this year which is kind of crazy
so with the iphone 7 pro they've been
talking about having the dual camera so
this is actually a pretty cool kind of
example of what you can do with the dual
cameras and I'm hoping that Apple does
something you know kind of reinvented
like they sort of did with the live
photos even though I don't ever use the
live photos and they kind of upset me
when I accidentally have them on because
then I'm taking the photo and then
accidentally send this set photo to my
friends and then I'm saying something
stupid or then it's like this awful
picture and it doesn't even actually
work so sometimes I think live photos
might not be the coolest thing ever
I've been a huge fan of the intel
realsense cameras which are able to
sense depth so this is a great example
of how you'll be able to use different
adjustments to sort of blur the
background or go and fix in post how you
want the focus to be which is going to
be really cool for people who are
shooting photos on the go and you're
just trying to get a cool shot so I love
this video
demo that he has here at the end where
it kind of shows you on this phone how
that could actually work
thank you check insider for this
fantastic demo so here's another article
from 9 to 5 Mac talking about again
those 7 pro schematics to show up in
Japanese magazine with dual camera and
smart connector oh that's something that
I actually didn't mention there
potentially going to be having the smart
pen sir on the iphone 7 pro which was
first introduced in the iPad pro so the
smart connector in the iPad you're able
to add a keyboard and it's a full
functioning keyboard that connects using
the smart connector so it'll be
interesting to see what Apple decides to
do with this another thing it's also
been sort of interesting that I've been
reading is a lot of people saying that
probably not for the iPhone 7 but maybe
for the iPhone 7s Apple could do away
with the lightning cable and switch to
the USB C port so as I was editing this
I have this thought okay if they are
going to remove the headphone jack and
then
gonna remove the lightning cable in
iphone 7s it would make sense that in
the seven that day not only remove the
headphone jack but they might as well
just remove for the lightning cable and
replace it with USB C because you might
as well just kill all of the birds with
all of the stones in one shot which is a
really terrible analogy but I feel like
if you're gonna screw people over by
removing the headphone jack you might as
well screw them over twice remove the
lightning cable and start integrating
USB C headphones USB C is way more
Universal than lightning cables so if
they do create USB C headphones it would
make so much more sense to do it
immediately because they'll already be
able to get these onto the market other
phones will then be able to use them and
then we're third-party companies will be
creating more headphones for more
devices I'm not really sure if any of
this makes sense but in my head it
definitely hundred percent makes sense
but I feel like a lot of people are
going to be super pissed if that is the
case but Apple users are always mad and
we're always excited about something so
either way I feel like if that's the
route that Apple does decide to go it is
the way that they are going to be
pushing the industry I mean you know I
think about when they remove the floppy
drive I was like guys you can't do this
but guess what they did and they were
right never used a floppy drive ever
again would they remove the CD drives
from pretty much every computer I was
very very upset because I was like wow
how am I gonna function I function just
fine
so for me this actually makes the most
sense and even going back and looking at
the schematic that could potentially be
the USB C port I think it looked
actually a little well that looks about
the same I feel like if they're gonna do
it they're gonna need to do it soon
because people are gonna waste time and
effort and money on creating lightning
cable headphones and that's not going to
be around for a while so you're
basically just gonna be wasting more
money so maybe that's their plan I don't
know now I'm getting too really stressed
out just thinking about it my weekend is
ruined back to this video so here's
another article talking about iPhone 7
to release for new phones in 2016 so
we've sort of already discussed that
which is kind of crazy that they will be
releasing four new phones when people
aren't upgrading phones as fast as they
used to I mean they make it so difficult
I don't know they've been doing these
new edge plans which technically you're
still paying for the phone but you're
paying for it monthly and then at the
end you switch in your phone and get
another one
they are just ripping us off
and right like the phone companies you
guys are beyond absurd like I still have
unlimited data on AT&T but then if I hit
a certain threshold they're like oh we
just want to let you know we realized
that you have unlimited data but we're
going to slow down the service after you
hit 30 gigs this month that is not
unlimited I've been with you guys for so
long and it makes me very very fussy
there's definitely going to be a change
at some point coming very soon for these
phone companies because it's insanity so
yeah I just wanted to chat a little bit
about some things that I saw before we
head into the weekend here a lot of you
guys kept tweeting me and wanted to know
more about what was happening and really
there's not much I think just with the
release of the schematic it definitely
does confirm there will not be a
headphone jack in the iPhone 7 there
will potentially be two versions if not
three a smaller iPhone 7 and iPhone 7
plus and iphone 7 pro which will have
the dual camera and it's going to be
pretty cool to see the capabilities that
we'll be able to do having a dual camera
on I guess the back I was gonna say the
front because that would be the back of
the phone so yeah that's uh basically it
I hope you guys have a great weekend let
me know in the comments below any of
your thoughts on the iPhone 7 or even
the iPhone 7s which we'd actually we're
talking about because in case you missed
it
there has been some huge news that new
iPhone 7s which we haven't released the
seven yet so it's kind of crazy that
we're already talking about the 7s which
we're probably talking about the 7s
because the iPhone 7 is going to almost
look identical to the success in the 6
plus so we need something to talk about
but the iPhone 7s has been rumored to be
made of all glass which if you remember
the iPhone 4 and 4s those were all glass
phones and those things shattered so
easily so hopefully Apple does have that
figured out I know what the Apple watch
is having the sapphire glass has been
really awesome
I have not shattered any of my Apple
watches I've dropped them a few times
and I don't know if that means anything
now I may have just jinxed myself and
now I'm gonna go outside today and my
other watch will be shattered and I'll
be very very sad about it I've also been
thinking about doing a video top 10
things I don't like about Apple and I've
been debating it because everyone keeps
calling me an Apple fan girl and I'm the
biggest
fangirl ever yeah you know what I am I
love their products there's things that
upset me there's things that I love
about Microsoft there's things I don't
love about Microsoft it's sort of a
love-hate relationship when I think
every sort of pretty much everything in
life really I typically choose to not
really say anything negative you know if
you don't anything I used to say just
don't say anything at all i a few things
didn't upsetting me recently about Apple
and I was like should I talk about it
should I not talk about it I'm not
really sure let me know what you guys
think and also feel free to make your
top ten things that you don't like about
Apple and also maybe your top ten things
that you do like about Apple because
there's so many incredible things and I
mean this company even for me their
products have changed my life and
they've changed so many people's lives
so I'm by no means hating on them I
think it's just been a sort of a
difficult time for Apple now officially
not having things the steve job has
worked on i mean we may never know how
many things few jobs has currently
touched that are being released but i
think we all know that when we lost
Steve Jobs Apple definitely would never
be the same and I think Tim Cook was
doing an incredible job and everyone
there is you know trying to sort of fill
that void that Steve left sort of in our
lives and in the company and and the
world really that's all I've got to say
I think I hope you guys have a great
weekend and happy uh happy Friday
see you guys later oh okay all right oh
oh wait I think that you should try it
oh that is a good in there even better
you wanted some Oh green right